[Music]
the silence felt like it stretched to
infinity
and my face was beat red frozen like a
deer in headlights i stammered for words
finally i heard the voice of my general
partner come in and swoop in to save me
like a remote and distant loudspeaker
from some far off planet bringing me
back to the present to the sandhill road
conference room to the perfect square of
california sunshine in front of me
nina is not an executive assistant
she is an associate partner at this firm
a huge wave of relief washed over me and
i let out the breath i didn't even
realize i had been holding
i tell you guys a story because it is
literally one of the most cringe-worthy
moments of my entire life but also it
because it is the moment
that i felt like an absolute outsider in
venture capital
i felt like an outsider because i was a
22 year old female in this old boys club
of venture capital and the truth was i
probably was never going to fit in
today only sixteen percent of venture
capital investors are women
and only three percent of all of venture
capital in america goes to female ceos
this is crazy to me
my experiences as a recovering venture
capitalist and now as the founder of my
own
y commenter back startup
are just incredibly difficult for me to
talk about
because i have gone through all of the
stages of grief about how capital is
allocated in our country
denial
anger just so much anger and rage
how is it that this group of just
incredibly well-meaning people
who are my friends who are my mentors
could yield such systematically unequal
outcomes how is it that an industry that
is considered by most to be the most
meritocratic in the world
has portfolio
that look the way that they do
and finally i circled back to optimism
optimism because all of the amazing
female founders that i've met here at
stanford and all the amazing female
investors i know are going to go on to
change things in venture capital
i'm here to help you skip all of those
stages of grief that i went through and
jump to that optimism part as well
i want to start by just talking about
some of the biggest reasons i think
exist for this persistent gap in funding
the first
is the pipeline problem but probably not
in the way that you think
yes women only get 20 of the computer
science degrees in this country
but the real problem is that we are
using that as a pipeline to figure out
who gets funded
this outdated investment criteria that
technical chops are somehow a
prerequisite for being a startup ceo is
absolute [ __ ]
we need to get rid of these archetypes
we have in our head of what an ideal
startup founder looks like
having moved to the operator side now i
can tell you there is an enormous
laundry list of things that you need to
be
and great ceo
nowhere on that list is knowing how to
write a single line of code and we need
to make sure that women are not opting
themselves out because they don't check
off all of these boxes
the second which i know all too well is
the lack of diversity in the decision
makers in this country
it's funny
how the people that
you happen to trust just look a hell of
a lot like you and all of those original
early stage venture capital decisions
are built on trust
one thing i learned in venture capital
is that sourcing is often playing
basketball with your harvard fraternity
brothers
the people that you trust
just happen to look a hell of a lot like
you
maybe they went to the same schools as
you maybe they were in the same
fraternity
you have to check those types of things
the last is unconscious bias
in an hbs study published in 2017
researchers found that when women walk
in for a pitch
they are way more likely to get
questions that are about the potential
risks of the business versus the
potential gains
even when giving identical pitches as a
male ceo
as a result even when women are given
the opportunity to pitch
they often are overlooked
this is equivalent to asking one set of
yelp reviewers in which in what way
was your food michelin star
and asking a different set of yelp
reviewers
in what way did your server screw up
your meal
the real world is obviously
a lot more subtle than that
but all of us have these unconscious
biases that impact the way that we make
decisions in this world
i wanted to take a moment to just
reflect on
why this matters so much in the world
venture capital is a tiny industry but
it is an important gatekeeper to the
types of ideas that end up existing in
this world
what kind of amazing ideas are we
missing out on because the group of
people we are backing come from such a
small homogenous and elite group
second equity returns are a huge driver
of wealth creation in this country
fifty percent of all fortune 500
companies originally vc or angel backed
so if you look at all of those
inequities all the systematic wealth
inequities in this country a lot of
those originate
at an earlier stage than you would think
at how capital is allocated
in the beginning
and to whom capital gains accrue
both on the founder and funder side
what i've said today
for women holds true for so many other
groups as well
these marginalized communities are also
in need of allies
lastly y'all are just missing out on
some crazy outsized returns
companies founded by women
are faster to reach profitability
they're more capital efficient
they literally return twice as much per
capital invested
as with most asset classes it pays to
invest in the underdog
this past year marked a record inflow of
capital into venture capital
and yet
over that same time period the
percentage of women getting allocated
that capital actually decreased
it pisses me off in so many ways to see
the numbers slide backwards
from three percent to something even
lower than three percent
yet there is also so much to be
optimistic about last year also marked
one of the biggest ipos ever by a female
founder in stitch fix
and one of the largest funding rounds
ever in women's health which has just
been an area that has been so
systematically under invested in for
generations
we still have so far to go to get to 50
but we have so much to be proud of and
to celebrate as well
i am tired and sick of waiting on the
sidelines for the numbers to change
i am in a room of movers and shakers and
i know that if we commit to this
we can change it
i'd love to re-center again
on the things that really matter and the
things that we can do
to the women in this room
who are founders
you inspire me
to be a better version of myself
thank you and i'm with you
i will be your hype woman for life
to the women who are considering
entrepreneurship but holding themselves
back for whatever reason
i believe in you
and you should own that space
to the allies in the room
we need you
to believe in us to mentor us to invest
in us
and lastly to the investors in the room
change the face of your industry
it is not enough to just hire a token
female junior team member
it is exhausting to be
the token junior
female team member
the solution is to hire at least two
but recognize that you will need to
mentor them
they will face just a immeasurable
uphill challenges as torch bearers in
the industry of venture capital
and lastly
find and fund people who don't look like
you
because it literally makes financial
sense to do so but also because it is
the right thing to do
i know that the next mark zuckerberg
will not look like him
that founder is probably in this room
go be her go work for her or go fund her
because i know she will return your
entire fund
thank you
[Music]
you